in early 2017 two women were approached
by a Japanese YouTube channel to
participate in a prank show what kind of
prank well for a hundred dollars all
they would have to do is run up to a
stranger smear their face with baby oil
or moisturizer apologize and then run
away the two women happily accepted so
for weeks donkey hung from Vietnam and
CT Aja from Indonesia would carry out
that same prank on camera each time the
mysterious man would tell them exactly
what to wear who the prank and even
where to smear the oil it was easy money
a hundred dollars a hundred dollars a
hundred dollars so the woman kept at it
by the time February 2017 came around
city and Don were brought to the Kuala
Lumpur Airport in Malaysia this time
their target was one of the Travelers at
the airport as usual their producers
pointed out the targets poured baby oil
in their hands and then sent them off
and as always the Tian dong ran up to
the men that were pranking smeared his
face for oil apologize and then ran off
except this time was very different this
time their target would drop dead from
the prank lesson 20 minutes later who
was their targets why none other than
Kim jong-nam the older half-brother of
North Korean dictator Kim Jong-un yes
that is right these two women had just
unknowingly assassinated a member of the
Kim Dynasty but this was no mistake no
this was a carefully planned out
perfectly executed assassination and
these women were just the useful idiots
this assassination was pulled off so
well that to this day no one has been
punished for it stay dangerous and this
is the assassination of Kim jong-nam
foreign
was living it up he got an allowance
from his dad so he was constantly
partying but unfortunately for Kim
jong-nam he was not using an extra
wallet to hold all that money if you
don't know extra is hands down the best
wallet out there I've been using it for
years has held up perfectly it's fast as
thin as classy as RFID blocking it can
hold both cards and cash it's super
satisfying to use it gets you
compliments that's a real leather
version which is my favorite there's
also an aluminum one they've got a 100
day risk-free trial it's basically
everything you could ever want in a
wallet and more it's my favorite gift to
give people because people are always
pumped when they see it and I take this
over a Louis Vuitton wallet that costs
10 times more any day of the week and
they've got some equally classy
accessories too like this minimalist
laptop sleeve that fits my 14 inch
MacBook perfectly and you can get up to
25 off until November 4th when you use
the code Jake Trent at checkout or shop
using the linkshop.exer.com so click the
link below to get up to 25 off until
November 4th no Hector was one of the
first sponsors to support this channel
so we're glad to have them back
Kim jong-nam was born in May 1971 in
Pyongyang North Korea
first born son of the supreme leader he
was raised for leadership right from the
starts he grew up in a mansion with more
than 100 servants and 500 guards he
often visited his father's office and
even while his dad found a new mistress
and had two more Sons everyone knew that
Kim jong-nam was destined to take the
throne but with a new woman in the
picture Kim jong-nam's dad didn't want
to draw too much attention to his affair
so he quietly sent his firstborn son Kim
jong-nam to an elite private school in
Switzerland the plan was to have him
educated there and then he will return
to take over once his father died and
for a while it seemed like everything
was going according to plan on his 24th
birthday Kim Jong now was made a general
in North Korea's secret police and he
was given a spot in his death political
party but here's the thing in North
Korea the supreme leader isn't just a
president or dictator he is seen as a
God and as a God the supreme leader is
expected to be able to do a lot of
things regular humans can't stuff like
never having to use a toilet because his
body is just so well calibrated or you
know learning how to drive at the age of
three so while Kim jong-nam was learning
to be a ruthless dictator North Korean
State media start to spread stories
about all his amazing achievements and
Godlike abilities they were preparing
the populist to accept their new ruler
the only problem was Kim jong-nam didn't
seem all that interested in nuking his
enemies and starving millions of people
he had gotten a taste of the outside
world and after spending years in Europe
life in North Korea became depressing
Kim jong-nam missed the freedom and
luxury he had become used to in the west
and pretty soon his father began to
notice his discontents the supreme
leader began to realize that his
firstborn son did not have what it took
to take over the kingdom and soon the
supreme leader was proving rights in
2001 Kim jong-nam was arrested for
trying to sneak into Japan using a fake
passport according to him all he wanted
to do was visit Disneyland but for North
Korea and his father it was the ultimate
embarrassment here was the government
doing everything in his power to prove
that the West Was evil and then the
Supreme Leader's son gets caught trying
to go into Disneyland what sort of
picture did that paint for the West Kim
jong-unha brought so much shame onto his
entire family and country that he was
exiled from North Korea yes the
firstborn son was banned from ever
setting foot in North Korea again much
let's be honest that is the best
punishment you could ask for Kim
jong-nam was forced to live in Exile in
Macau the Las Vegas of China and while
his father was still alive he still
received a yearly allowance that let him
live in relative Comforts but with
plenty of enemies in the North Korean
government and no idea who would be
taking his father's Throne Kim Jong-un
needed to align himself with a few
powerful friends and who better to go to
for help than North Korea's number one
enemy America
foreign
[Music]
's Exile spread it didn't take long for
the CIA to try to recruit him as an
informant as the man who has been
groomed to take over his father's role
who knew what kind of valuable
information he would be able to share
about North Korea but the CIA would have
to move quickly while Kim jong-nam was
still fresh out of North Korea his
knowledge would be Priceless but the
longer he spent in Exile the more
outdated his Intel would become luckily
for the CIA it didn't take much to
convince them to talk his whole life Kim
Jong nav had enjoyed a life of luxury he
was used to living it up in five-star
hotels and casinos but now his Exile
allowance was just not cutting it and he
would do anything for just a little bit
more money for girls in designer clothes
money the CIA was happy to provide over
the years Kim jong-nam would become one
of the ca's most important North Korean
informants even though he didn't always
have the latest information on North
Korea he knew better than anyone how the
government and the family functioned and
since he never planned on going back to
North Korea anyways he didn't really see
the harm in sharing a little information
in exchange for cash whenever the CAA
needed information he would fly to sing
airport or Malaysia to meet with his
handlers for nearly a decade Kim
jong-nam would live in the shadows as a
snitch handing out whatever sensitive
information he had for a quick payday
and never really worrying about the
consequences there was no way his dad
would find out and even if he did there
was no way he was going to kill his own
son as long as his father was alive
nothing would happen to him but not even
the supreme leader of North Korea is
Immortal and in 2011 Kim Jong-il finally
died heading over North Korea to his
youngest son Kim Jong-un
to Kim jong-nam his little half-brother
taking the throne was a joke and Kim
jong-nam was the no time badmouthing his
brother and his ability to lead the
country and an email to a Japanese
journalist Kim jong-nam called the new
supreme leader a joke to the outside
world and predicted his government
wouldn't last very long big mistake see
unlike his dad Kim Jong-un had no reason
to keep his older half-brother around to
Kim Jong-un his older brother was just
an embarrassing liability and a threat
to his Rule and so he did what every
other North Korean dictator had done to
the enemies before him he issued a
standing order to take out his brother
at any time by any means necessary so
while Kim jong-nam spent CIA money
partying in Macau completely oblivious
that his brother had just put a hit out
on him the government of North Korea was
carefully planning out his assassination
the hunt was on
in 2012 a North Korean secret agent was
arrested trying to enter South Korea
after a tough interrogation he broke and
began spilling all his secrets and one
of those Secrets was that he had been
involved in a failed attempt to kill Kim
jong-nam according to the agents he had
received a special order directly from
pong Yang to terminate Kim jong-nam and
bring his body back to North Korea North
Korean intelligence have found out that
Kim jong-nam was planning on traveling
to China where they wanted their agent
to grab a taxi driver to run him over in
an unfortunate traffic accident but Kim
jong-nam never showed up to China that
day and the plan was eventually scrapped
North Korea may have failed the first
assassination attempt but now the word
was out and it terrified Kim jong-nam so
he went from a partying Playboy to a
quiet Family Man almost instantly no
more going to clubs or traveling all
over the world instead he did his best
to stay in Macau where the Chinese
government could at least offer himself
on protection but not even that would
keep North Korea from trying to kill him
again the same year by the end of 2012
Kim jong-nam was so desperate that he
even sent his younger brother a letter
begging for his life in the letter he
wrote please withdraw the order to
punish me in my family we have nowhere
to hide the only way to escape is to
choose suicide but Kim Jong-un isn't
known for his forgiveness and that was
something his older brother knew all too
well for the next five years Kim
jong-nam did everything he could to stay
under the radar he really went out and
only traveled when he absolutely had to
and as long as he kept providing useful
Intel to the CIA and Chinese
intelligence he could count on love for
protection so whenever they make contact
with him he made sure to give them
everything they needed and that's
exactly what happened in early 2017 when
the CIA contacted him once again asking
him to come to Malaysia to meet one of
their agents Kim jong-nam knew he would
have to go he needed to ask them for
cash and to make sure that they still
had his back little did he know that his
every move was being watched by a team
of North Korean agents so as he planned
his upcoming to Malaysia they concocted
the perfect plan to finish him off
thank you
for the North Koreans plans to work they
would need to have as little contact as
possible with Kim jong-nam Not only
would they stop him from realizing what
was happening too early on it will also
make it easier for them to get away with
that assassination in the end if they
were going to succeed and take out Kim
jong-nam they would need to find two
scapegoats two innocent puppets who had
no idea they were being used luckily for
them Malaysia and most other countries
around it are filled with poor migrants
and people who desperately needed jobs
and it didn't take long for them to find
exactly the kind of recruits they were
looking for they found safety Asia
working as an escort in a shady hotel in
Kuala Lumpur the capital of Malaysia
[Music]
was recruited from a bar where she
worked on the Vietnamese capital of
Hanoi both girls were told the exact
same story that the North Korean agents
who approached them were actually a
Japanese producers of a popular YouTube
prank show and they were looking for
girls to act in their latest video
series and for each prank they were
willing to pay a hundred US dollars for
City and Dong it sounded like a dream
come true a hundred dollars was more
than what they made in a week at their
regular jobs and who would care about
two young girls playing a few harmless
pranks like the ones they saw online so
they took the jobs over the next few
weeks was City and Dong would visit
malls hotels and busy streets across
Kuala Lumpur and Hanoi each time their
Japanese producers were shot on their
targets for baby oil or moisturizer into
their hands and send them off on their
prank each time the girls will run up to
their targets smear their face with oil
apologize and then run away according to
the producers there were hidden cameras
all over the areas where the pranks took
place and the better the girls performed
the more they would get paid they even
told them that one day they would take
them to America to film for the first
few months City and Dong couldn't
believe their luck they were making
hundreds of dollars every single week by
pulling off easy harmless pranks and
since none other victims ever seem to
get angry or annoyed by Lum they didn't
have to feel guilty about what they were
doing for two girls that came from
poverty this opportunity was everything
they could have ever hoped for so when
the producers of their videos approached
them what another prank job this time at
the Kuala Lumpur international airports
they were more than happy to obey little
did they know that this next prank would
change their lives forever
foreign
[Music]
Malaysia was the perfect location for a
North Korean political assassination you
see Malaysia is one of the few countries
in the world where North Koreans can
travel without a Visa which meant that
this show would be the government's best
shot at taking down Kim jong-nam so
while Cynthia and Dong practiced their
pranks around Malaysia and Vietnam four
North Korean men arrive in Malaysia as
early as January 31st each of the men
landed on a different day with the last
arriving on February 7th just one day
after Kim jong-nam the North Koreans
have been on his tail from the moment he
left Macau they had spies on his plane
spies waiting for him at the airport
when he arrived and spies watching the
hotel where he stayed 24 7. they watched
as Kim jong-nam met with a man that they
suspected to be a CIA agent and they
watched as he left the meeting with 120
000 in cash in a bag they watched as Kim
jong-nam planned his return to Macau
they even knew the exact date and time
he would be leaving Malaysia February
13th so they let City and Dong know
about their next prank and this time the
two girls will be working together at
Kuala Lumpur international airports the
airport was the perfect location for an
assassination because each of the North
Koreans involved would be able to pass
through immigration and leave the
country before anyone even understood
what had happened
and so on the morning of February 13th
Kim jong-nam took a car to their
airports and little did he know that in
less than an hour he would be dead
[Music]
February 13th 2017 entering Kuala Lumpur
Airport in the gray suit the CCTV
appears to show Kim jong-nam he
continues into the busy departures Hall
unaware the two female assassins are
also at the airport while a tam Kim
jong-nam arrived at Kuala Lumpur
International Airport City down and
their Japanese producers were already
there waiting for him sitting at
opposite sides of the departure Hall
they carefully went over their plans
though City and Don would be pranking
the same person in the space of a few
seconds first city would approach him
Smither oil across his face apologize
and then leave quickly and then dong
would do the same thing straight after
both girls were told that after they
were done they would go to the bathroom
wash their hands and catch a taxi back
to the city if they follow the
instructions wall their producers
promised them a big bonus just before
9am Kim jong-nam arrives at the airport
and makes his way into the departures
Hall City's producer points him out to
her he's wearing jeans and a gray jacket
and carrying a dark backpack with her
Target in sight City's producer tells
her to stick out her hand look away she
does what she's told and he pours a
strange smelling oil into her hand
across the hall the same thing happens
to thong as City gets up to play her
prank her producer reminds her to
apologize and leave quickly after she's
done because her Target looks Rich she
nods and makes her way towards Kim Dong
Nam who is standing in line at the check
encounter with no idea what's about to
happen there are Lookout men a chemist
to handle the nerve agent a getaway
driver
team leader
codenamed Grandpa within Second City ran
up the kinjanam rubbed the oil onto his
face apologize and then disappeared
moments later throng approaches and does
the exact same thing before rushing away
for Kim jong-nam Panic set in
he knew his brother was out to get him
and now it seemed like his time had
finally come terrified he rushes to
airport staff trying to explain what
happened but no one knows or cares who
he is and so the best thing they can do
is walk him over to the airport clinic
by the time he reaches the clinic he is
in extreme pain his muscles are cramping
and he's struggling to breathe a North
Korean agent with a black suitcase
walked past to make sure that the poison
is taking effect before making his way
to immigration the clinic doctors call
for an ambulance and try to keep him
alive but it is too late Kim Jong now's
last words were very painful very
painful I was sprayed liquid he died
less than 20 minutes after the attack by
the time the Malaysian authorities
realized what happened all the North
Korean agents at the airport were long
gone they have flown back to pong Yang
using rust they knew wouldn't get them
detained leaving City and Dong to take
all the blame for what had just happened
thank you
[Music]
all it took for the Malaysian police to
figure out what had happened was a few
minutes of CCTV footage in their minds
it was clear that the two women in the
video were the ones responsible for
murdering Kim jong-nam but how had they
done it if the oil they had smeared on
his face was poisonous wouldn't they
have died too an examination of Kim
jong-nao's body finally uncovered the
truth a swab of his face revealed that
he had been poisoned with a special
version of a powerful nerve agent called
VX only when the two oils of city and
Dong's hands combined did it form the
Delhi poison which is why both girls
managed to survive to Malaysian police
it looked like an open and shut case the
girls had been recruited by North Korea
to poison Kim jong-nam and within days
of the attack while City and dog have
been arrested to stand trial for murder
if they were found guilty they would be
sensed to death by hanging even as
cities sat in jail she still believed
that it was all part of the prank
neither she or dong had any idea what
they had done but over the next few
months in court their lawyers would
slowly unravel one of the most daring
assassination plots in history and the
level of planning that went into the
attack was almost unbelievable first the
two men that had City and Dong were not
Japanese in reality they were both North
Korean agents tasked to get the girls to
trust them and do as they say and
nothing about the stories they had toast
City and dog have been real not even the
practice pranks they had done have been
real victims instead each person
targeted had either been North Korean or
were recruited by North Koreans to
participate in the show that way there
would never be any real victims who
would call the police or bring attention
to the prank it was obvious that City
and dang had never known what the North
Koreans were really planning which meant
the real killers were still out there of
the entire North Korean team sent to
kill Kim jong-nam only three of them
stayed behind in Malaysia and all three
were hiding at the North Korean emcee
including the chemists responsible for
creating the modified version of the VX
poison Malaysian police managed to get a
video of the chemist trying to get his
story straight with the embassy
officials
[Music]
and for the first time in the
investigation it looked like the police
had the right man he was real evidence
that it wasn't North Koreans were
responsible for it but it didn't matter
the North Korean government had planned
for all contingencies if Malaysia didn't
want to let the three North Koreans
leave the country North Korea would just
have to block all of Malaysia's Embassy
staff that were in North Korea from
leaving too they were holding the
malaysian's hostage in exchange for the
release of their agents and it worked
less than two months after the attack
the Malaysian government caved and
allowed all three men to return home Kim
Jong-un and the North Korean government
had gotten away with murder on foreign
soil but the same couldn't be said for
City and Dong they spent the next two
years finding their charges and even
though they were eventually cleared and
allowed to go free Malaysia let the real
killers of Kim jong-nam get away leaving
a brutal assassination to go unpunished
and you want to know who else got away
with murder YouTube
O.J Simpson
when OJ killed Nicole Brown and Ron
Goldman there was an insane amount of
evidence against OJ it looked like an
open and shut case and yet OJ still got
away with it but how exactly well as OJ
Simpson you had three things going for
you one you were able to put together
the dream team of the very best lawyers
two there were a lot of racial tensions
at the time so you were able to play the
race card and three while everyone's
eyes were fixated on you no one stopped
to think that there might have been a
second killer alongside you that's right
there was a second killer a second
killer that escaped The public's
Consciousness to this very day and this
would be your Ace in the Hole and so you
and your loras put together the greatest
defense plan ever to manipulate the jury
into saying not guilty of the crime of
murder and we expose it all in our new
documentary on our new channel called
how to get away with it that you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the screen
thank you